pour toi ce que Dieu donnait est sincère
dans son pardon parce que on va parler
après de ton projet avec lui oui écoute
franchement moi je n'ai aucun doute
là-dessus d'ailleurs si tu veux être
assuré de sa sincérité il faut que tu
écoutes la réponse qu'il a faite à Soral
c'est marrant c'est tous ces gens qui
ont besoin de la haine il y a des gens
qui ont besoin de la haine ils étaient
très proches avec Alain Soral et ce qui
lui a fait comme réponse ce qu'il m'a
dit il faut que tu écoutes mais c'est
pas tu peux pas me le dire c'est long
mais si tu veux en gros Alain Soral lui
reproche
de demander pardon à la communauté
exactement d'ailleurs comme le le CRIF
lui reproche aussi et de demander pardon
la communauté et ça c'est un des
miracles de finalement de la du repentir
de de Dieudonné c'est que pour la
première fois quand même Soral et le
CRIF sont mains dans la main ils sont
sur la même ligne
poser des questions il y a eu tellement
de choses
ni oublie ni pardon c'est à dire le gars
il monte une un mouvement qui s'appelle
Égalité et Réconciliation et quand
quelqu'un veut se réconcilier ben il
l'insulte il injurie etc donc moi je
trouve que il y a des des gens qui ont
besoin dans la société de la haine
se pose des questions c'est normal un
moment non c'est vrai moi j'aimerais
bien que le clip se pose des questions
mais là il y répond c'est à dire que le
cri fait un procès d'intention à
Dieudonné non mais après après tu les
gens ne sont pas obligé de pardonner non
il y a des gens voilà c'est après faut
faire on peut faire des trucs très
graves demain je vais faire un truc très
grave et je vais dire bah excusez-moi le
lendemain je vais pas je veux dire
pardon les gens sont pas obligés de le
pardonner après il y en a qui ont envie
de le pardonner il y en a qui sont tout
le monde n'est pas obligé personne n'est
obligé de pardonner mais on peut pas
empêcher quelqu'un de demander pardon
il s'agit d'empêcher quelqu'un de
demander pardon et personne ne peut nous
obliger à calmer personne et d'ailleurs
c'est pas le souhait de d'ailleurs il a
dit dans sa première il a dit il a dit
je ne cherche aucune excuse car nul n'en
a lorsqu'il est conscient qu'il a
offensé et qu'il a fait du tort à autrui
alors c'est pas des excuses Cyril quand
tu demandes pardon tu te cherches pas
d'excuses c'est-à-dire que tu Soulages
ta conscience tu Soulages ta conscience
parce que tu penses que tu as nuit à
donc moi je dis simplement que là
aujourd'hui manifestement au moment où
Dieudonné fait un acte de repentir il y
a des gens qui lui font un procès
d'intention parce que très probablement
ils n'ont pas intérêt à ce que Dieudonné
perd de cette image
erronée d'antisémite voilà après moi sur
ça voilà je me dis les gens c'est normal
que ils ont été beaucoup de gens étaient
extrêmement échaudés extrêmement choqués
par toutes ces déclarations à un moment
voilà ils peuvent aussi avoir un doute
alors pourquoi se revirement le
Dieudonné tu sais alors c'est très
marrant la manière dont ça s'est passé
parce que moi j'étais un des plus
virulents des tracteurs de Dieudonné
j'ai dit des choses mais terribles sur
lui et d'ailleurs j'en ai même dit qui
était contraire à mes valeurs et
moi-même je me suis choqué d'avoir dit
ça et tu sais moi je je me convoque tous
les jours à mon propre tribunal et quand
j'ai fait quelque chose de pas bien ben
je me condamne et la première chose que
je fais je vais voir la personne à qui
j'ai tort et je lui demande pardon et
moi vis-à-vis de lui même si j'étais
absolument totalement hostile assez
assez test ce que je peut-être ces thèse
j'estimais que j'avais j'avais
outrepassé mon droit humain et que je
l'avais je l'avais agressé que j'avais
dit des choses que je regrettais d'avoir
dites parce que c'était pas conforme à
mes valeurs j'ai dit qu'il un type comme
lui ne devrait même pas avoir le droit
de parler alors je suis allé le voir et
je lui ai dit alors que tu étais
extrêmement colère contre lui c'est toi
qui a demandé aller voir tu l'as et
c'est moi qui ai demandé à mon ami Chloé
Framery dont je savais qu'elle était son
ami il ne me donnait son numéro de
téléphone et je l'ai appelé et là je lui
ai dit écoute voilà moi j'exécre tout ce
que tu es tout ce que tu dis tout ce que
tu fais mais je je pense mettre mal
comporté envers toi avoir dit des choses
que je regrette et comme je pense qu'un
être humain normal doit le faire je te
demande pardon d'avoir fait ça et là à
ce moment-là c'est toi qui va demander
pardon oui je vais demander pardon parce
que je pense que j'étais allé trop loin
dans ce que j'avais dit et lui je me
suis jugé comme ça pardon
parce que quelqu'un fait quelque chose
de mal pour faire la même chose donc moi
c'est le droit de réagir avec aussi j'ai
le droit de réagir jusqu'à une certaine
mesure j'ai dit des choses moi le
combattant de la liberté d'expression
j'ai dit qu'il n'avait pas le droit de
s'exprimer je regrette d'avoir dit ça il
y a des choses sur lesquelles un moment
je je te rejoins il a été beaucoup trop
loin ah oui mais d'ailleurs si il
s'excuse aujourd'hui s'il demande pardon
c'est parce que lui-même juge qu'il est
allé trop loin sinon il demanderait pas
pardon et donc avec beaucoup plus loin
que toi dans tes paroles envers lui je
trouve ben c'est pas tu sais c'est pas
les Jeux olympiques de de du maldire
c'est pas les Jeux olympiques de de
l'offense donc alors qu'est-ce qui t'a
dit côté donc au moment où je lui
demande pardon il me dit écoute Francis
on est le jour de Pâques aujourd'hui
est-ce que tu penses vraiment qu'un
chrétien comme moi peut refuser ton
pardon et là je comprends qu'il est
chrétien parce que je pensais pas qu'il
était chrétien je pensais que c'était un
fondamentaliste qui se baladait avec une
ceinture d'explosif dans les banlieues
pour pour appeler à la destruction de
l'État d'Israël et en fait c'est un
chrétien militant comme moi un chrétien
pratiquant et il me dit tu sais quand tu
as dit ces choses là ça m'a blessé
profondément pas simplement moi mais ça
m'a blessé pour toi parce que je pense
que tu t'es abaissé à dire ces choses et
et il avait raison il m'en a remis une
deuxième c'est pour ça que je lui ai
demandé pardon et là au moment où je
vais partir il me dit est-ce que je peux
te demander quelque chose tu dis oui
est-ce que moi aussi je peux te demander
pardon parce que je sais que je t'ai
fait du tort il m'a fait du tort à
plusieurs moments dans des dispositifs
que j'avais mis en place j'étais très en
colère contre lui il le savait et je lui
dis bah écoute oui j'accepte ton pardon
mais est-ce que tu pourrais aller plus
loin je lui dis est-ce que par exemple
tu pourrais demander pardon à tous les
gens qui se sentent offensés parce que
tu as fait et dit notamment dans la
communauté juive il me dit Francis c'est
mon vœu le plus cher mais je n'arrive
pas à trouver quelqu'un qui accepte de
recevoir mon pardon et quand il m'a dit
ça tout d'un coup moi j'ai je me suis
dit que c'était
très important qu'il puisse le faire et
donc j'en ai fait une affaire
personnelle et je lui ai dit tu ne
connais pas cette communauté moi je la
connais bien je l'aime profondément et
il y a dans cette communauté des gens
qui bien sûr ne sont pas d'accord pour
recevoir ton pardon mais il y en a
beaucoup que tu offensés qui sont très
touchés par ton par ton message de ta
demande de pardon parce qu'en plus tu
leur ennuies à deux de deux manières tu
leur ennuies parce que tu les as
offensés mais surtout tu leur asnuie
parce que tu les as privé de leur
comique préféré parce que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui dans la communauté
juive qui adorait Dieudonné et puis et
puis qui quand il a commencé à dire ces
choses-là ben on était aussi privés de
leur comique préféré c'est pas le c'est
pas le premier truc auquel ils ont pensé
ils ont déjà été très choqué non mais
bien évidemment mais si je peux me
permettre je connais moi j'ai énormément
d'amis juifs et tu le sais pourquoi il
est sincère mais ça fait pas l'ombre
d'un doute et sinon moi je me j'aurais
jamais fait un spectacle avec mission
parce que tu vas faire jamais jamais six
mois si moi je pensais à un moment qui
avait une once de des gens qui disent
que vous faites un coup médiatique mais
les gens disent ce qu'ils veulent de moi
je te dis ce que je sens ce que je sais
qui a gagné ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr en
tout cas ce qui me concerne c'est sûr et
lui aussi d'ailleurs parce que lui il a
pas besoin de
tout ça pour gagner sa vie et pour
remplir les selles lui il a un truc il a
il a mis en place un système économique
parallèle qu'est-ce qui a fait juste
Francis il est qui l'a vrillé comme ça
qui s'est dit aujourd'hui j'ai envie
qu'on me demande pardon j'ai envie de
demander pardon de demander pardon mais
ça fait ça fait longtemps qu'il a cette
envie mais qu'il n'y arrive pas c'est à
dire qu'il n'arrive pas à parce qu'il
connaît pas bien cette communauté moi je
dis faut que je te présente des gens il
en est arrivé là à dire à faire des
trucs comme ça écoute ça c'est ça c'est
ce qui t'en a parlé ou bien sûr bien sûr
mais ça si tu veux je me demande si
c'est pas hors sujet parce que lui
effectivement il a il a des
circonstances atténuantes parce qu'il a
été embarqué il le dit lui-même il a eu
des mauvais démons pour de lui hein
circonstances atténuante on peut pas
accepter non mais le phrase lui-même
lui-même a dit qu'il n'en cherchait pas
lui-même a dit il n'en cherchait pas
dire comment est-ce qu'à un moment donné
alors qu'il n'est pas antisémite il
s'est trouvé en bringué dans dans toutes
ces choses affreuses qu'il a dit tu es
fait bon lui on déjà parlé mais je pense
que c'est pas le sujet lui si un jour tu
fais une émission là-dessus il te
l'expliquera moi il me l'a expliqué mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que le c'est
pas le sujet comment il en est arrivé à
faire le mal le sujet c'est j'ai fait le
mal et je demande pardon et quand on
refuse l'idée qu'il puisse demander
pardon c'est qu'on est en train de faire
le procès du pardon c'est pas son procès
à lui qu'on fait et je suis heureux que
Jean-Marie soit là parce que Jean-Marie
lui il sait ce que c'est que le pardon
et et le je pense que le pardon c'est
quelque chose qui élève notre âme
pardonner sa élève notre âme et demander
pardon ça élève notre âme